ADAM CHAMPY: Hello
and good morning.
My name is Adam Champy,
and I'm the product lead
on the Google Cast SDK.
And I figure since
it's 9:00 a.m.
On a Friday, it's
pretty appropriate
to talk about what most people
do in the evening, which
is connect to entertainment.
And for those of you who
were partying last night
or out the night
before as well, thank
you very much for getting
up early to join us today.
I'm first going to talk
about the next generation,
and this is my son, who
apparently really loves TV.
And my wife and I
literally bought
a device that tried to keep
him staring away from the TV.
But he's evolved.
He's learned to watch content
pretty much in any position.
But what's tricky
for us-- we hope
he doesn't love TV
as much as I do.
Honestly, I love
watching sports.
I love watching the Daily
Show, casting the Daily Show.
I love watching the Red Sox.
I live on the West Coast, so the
way I connect with the Red Sox,
which is a baseball
team on the East Coast,
is through the MLB app.
I also love watching
the Boston Celtics.
I especially like watching the
Boston Celtics beat the Golden
State Warriors, which are one
of the only teams to do that.
AUDIENCE: Boo.
ADAM CHAMPY: But
you know, I have
to take-- they're out of
the playoffs right now,
but the Warriors are
still in the playoffs.
So they're doing kind of well.
But the experience
that we have around
the media I'm talking
about, a lot of it
is driven by how we
connect to that media.
I like to watch the
Red Sox wherever I am.
I like to watch The Daily
Show if I'm traveling
or on the road.
I connect to that experience
via apps on my mobile devices,
my tablet or my phone.
And I also love that
experience of extending it
onto the most beautiful
displays in my home,
including the Visio P
series that's on the wall.
And this experience is
driven by Google Cast,
and that's what I'm going
to spend a bunch of time
today talking about.
And that experience is connected
to these larger screens
through what we call
the Cast button.
And I'll take you through
a little bit of the Cast
experience so that you're more
familiar with it for those
of you who aren't.
The Cast button
is a single button
that's added to any one
of the existing apps that
play media, video, or
audio that extends media
to the large screen, to extender
devices like Chromecast, cast
TVs, or Android TVs, as
well as audio devices.
So you can connect to
speakers in your home,
integrated speakers, or
cast for audio products,
or Chromecast audio, which
extends the audio experience
to your existing speakers.
And this is just a simple
press of the Cast button that
connects to this larger home.
We've enabled thousands of apps.
So for the end consumer,
this is awesome.
The apps they already have on
their phone or the tablet work.
They don't have to
do anything else.
For the developer,
this is what we're
going to talk about today.
And we're going to
talk about specifically
if you want to become
one of these apps,
or if you already are, what we
have in store in our new Google
Cast SDK.
And what's awesome about
this is it's also just going
to be fun today for if
you're just curious how
all this magic works.
We're very proud to launch
the new Google Cast SDK
and build in a ton
of the knowledge
that we've gained over the
past two or three years on how
to get this interaction right.
Some of the goals that
we have for this new SDK
are to improve that
user experience,
to make that simple button
press work beautifully,
to make the connection between a
mobile phone and the big screen
or speakers 100% reliable,
wonderful in every app.
And what's been
tricky in the past SDK
versions is we've asked
you the developers to take
on a lot of that burden,
and I talked a little bit
about this on the
Wednesday talk.
We're going to go
in a ton more detail
and actually cast enable all
the way through media an app.
And what's great
about the new SDK
is that in what we've done
to implement the entire UX--
And sometimes we call this
the Cast UX guidelines--
is that we've
provided almost all
of the elements of that
UX checklist in the SDK.
You have a default or built-in
behavior for every single one
of the elements.
And what's great about
this is this really
should reduce development time.
And to not just
take my word for it,
we've been having a small
early access program
to get feedback on this, to
see how the developers react.
And we're getting feedback that
on a first time development,
the new SDK reduces initial
development time by about 40%,
which is pretty large.
What's also great is
that we've implemented
the right abstractions,
and we're getting feedback
that they're at the right
level, such that maintenance
on our side and on the app side
should be much, much easier.
In particular, on the
iOS side of the SDK.
On Android, we had
built something
called the CCL or the
Cast Companion Library,
and that had informed us a lot
of what to do going forward.
So we incorporated those
learnings as well as
other technologies into the
new SDK for Android and iOS,
and we'll talk through
a lot more of the detail
in a few minutes.
For those of you who are new
to the Cast development model,
there's essentially four
major steps of Cast.
The first is discovery.
How does a mobile
device find out
if there's a Chromecast
or an Android TV
or a Cast TV or a cast
for audio speaker?
The next stage is
actually casting
where the user presses
that Cast button
and says I actually want
to make a connection.
And the app has to negotiate
that connection and launch
what's called a receiver
application on that cast
endpoint.
The third stage is control,
sending small messages
in between the two endpoints.
Because in the Cast
model, all of the media
and all of the data really
streams from the Cloud
to the Cast endpoint, making
the phone kind of just a control
center, not necessarily having
any media run through it.
And then if you have
to handle disconnect,
handling it gracefully.
The fourth is kind of
pervasive through all, which
is reconnect, what happens
in between if you change
Wi-Fi networks.
If you have something
that changes
in the status of connection
in general of your phone.
And historically, reconnect
was actually really tricky,
and we put a lot of the
burden in our previous SDKs
on the developer to handle
it and kind of reinvent
the wheel over and over there.
Specifically, we
interacted with a lot
of the lifecycle of your app
across these four major faces.
We did that in
discovery by asking
you to manage tons of
callbacks and pseudo state
management of what the
user is trying to do,
kind of replicating
our states in yours.
In control, we essentially
made you redo this
all over again by having you
create and manage, essentially,
a session in your own app
that matched our session.
We separated this experience.
What we've done in the new SDK
is implement the right state
management and the right
UX, such that we handle
the specifics of Cast and the
user experience associated
with it.
By delivering you, essentially,
a state manager and a UX that's
associated with Cast and getting
out of the details of your app.
What's awesome about
this is for maintenance,
we previously asked you
anytime we changed anything
in that lifecycle
of Cast to change
the lifecycle of your app.
Especially in iOS, this
was really difficult.
So even minor changes
would impact your app
quite a bit in ways that
sometimes you or we didn't
expect.
So what we've done is
implemented the abstraction
at the correct place, such
that you can do app development
independent of Cast,
and we can continue
to improve Cast and
deploy SDK updates that
really have minor, if not
any, impact on your app.
From the perspective
of migration,
what's actually really
cool about this too
is that migration looks a lot
more like ripping out code.
It's not going
through and finding,
I'm going to do it this
way here, that way here,
or the new way here,
the old way here.
It's actually changing
to a new model.
So it's a clean migration.
It's I take out this callback
and pseudo state management
aspects and move over
to the new concept.
And because we've
made it so easy
to implement the
first time, we also
believe that migrations
are going to be
very straightforward as well.
And we're going through a few
initial migrations right now.
The new features
that we're deploying
are along the lines
again of state management
as well as user experience.
Specifically, we're
delivering device discovery,
and we're also delivering
the whole Cast session
in a new way.
And I'll take you
through both of these.
We've also deployed a
reconnection service, which
is an optional component,
but on by default.
And this was familiar to those
of you who have used CCL.
But it's really new and
awesome for the iOS developer.
In addition to that, we're
delivering the entire Cast
button and root
logic so that you
don't have to worry about that.
It's so specific to
the Cast experience
that our SDK really
should handle all of it.
And then on the next
item, we're giving you
template controllers.
So if you're one of
those developers who's
looking at enabling
your app for Cast,
this gets you started way,
way faster, whether it's just
getting an MVP out the
gate or something that's
really production-ready,
because these controllers take
the best of our UX experience
in Cast and deliver it to you.
And when I say template,
I mean that you
can control what's on these
controllers and the actions
that the user can take
while still being adherent
to a standard that users
would understand across
multiple apps, as well as
standard in iOS or Android.
We've designed these
to be very native
and feel wonderful in
both of those experiences.
And I'll show you both of them.
The first area that
we're going to start with
is this concept of a
context or the singleton
that unifies all of
the state management.
What this does is it delivers
you a fully managed session,
from discovery through the
concept of casting media.
You don't have to
manage these in kind
of two different
separate ways, and you
don't have to deal with all
the complexities in each side.
We also provide you a
reconnection service in this.
Because we understand state
and because we understand
the transitions, we
also understand, well,
what if the connection
status has gone wrong
or changed in this state.
So we're able to do much
more on reconnection,
and this is an area that
we can innovate in quite
a bit on going forward as well.
The big takeaway
from this is calls
to Google API client going
forward are not needed.
You don't have to make this
kind of, again, pseudo state
management in your app
as well as kind of figure
out what the heck is
going on in the Cast SDK.
We're now going to actually
dive in and cast enable an app.
On the left, you see Android,
and on the right, you see iOS,
and we'll start on Android.
The first thing that you do
in initializing Cast context
is in the first chunk
of code, and I'll
simplify this for those
of you who don't read
50 lines of code super fast.
The first thing we
do is essentially
set the options for the context.
These options include do I
want debugging verbosity,
do I want to be able
to actually understand
what's going on in the SDK.
The other one is do I want
the reconnection service on.
That's pretty much it.
Essentially, set
up options and then
you lazily instantiate
the actual context.
The app that you're looking
at where this code is from
is from one of our Code Labs.
So you'll have a
ton of opportunity
to dig into this
exact same code when
we release the Code Labs later
this month or early in June.
What's awesome about this
is that this, essentially,
is a view where the user is
looking at different videos,
and in that view it's
really appropriate
to show a Cast button and
it's also really appropriate
to enable Cast.
So you can lazily
instantiate this context
when it's appropriate
in your app lifecycle.
Similarly on iOS, you
instantiate and create
a context options, and then you
instantiate the context itself.
This is about the simplest we
can make a context or state
manager with a set of options.
I mean, if you're
developing a singleton that
manages all states of an
SDK, this is about as simple
as we can do, essentially
a set of options
and instantiate the singleton.
What's great about
this experience
for the iOS developer is
this is a lot, a lot better.
If you haven't worked
with our previous SDK,
this is a huge
advancement in terms
of what you're going to get
for free coming forward.
The other aspect of this is
that we can now do discovery
in a much more simple way.
And what that discovery
is, is essentially
just creating a Cast button.
So once you've
created a Cast button,
you can essentially just
trust everything else
for free afterwards.
Creating a Cast button in
Android looks pretty simple.
Essentially all you do is
use a Cast button factory
to generate a button in
the colors that you need
and that the colors are
inherited in the same way
that you do in
Android UX in general.
And what's awesome about this is
you can just trust this method
to give you a fully functional
Cast button that does
all of the logic going forward.
So when the user presses
that Cast button,
they get all of the
route discovery for free
and you get all the
route discovery for free.
And if they back
out of this flow
you don't have to manage
callbacks to understand
whether or not the
user's kind of actually
casted or not casted, and you
understand the state of all
the different Cast endpoints.
In addition, you effectively get
knowledge in the reconnect of
whether or not the user
is already casting.
So the reason I show
the picture on the right
is that if you come back, or
the app's in the background
and you come back
to foreground, we
handle filling in
the Cast button,
and we handle figuring out is
the user already playing media.
That's in the SDK now.
Similarly, on the iOS side,
we use a factory method
to generate a Cast button.
And what you're starting
to see I'd say consistency
in is that the same way
you think about developing
for Android or the same way
that you think about structuring
your Android development,
we are taking to iOS.
And historically these
worlds were really far apart.
The ways that we asked
developers to work
were kind of night and
day, and what we're doing
is making the development
concepts and the architecture
concepts and the naming of
objects as close to possible
across the two.
So similarly, you have
a Cast button creator.
Now, it's kind of iOS friendly,
so if you're an iOS developer,
you'd understand the nature
of how we've structured it.
So we're not trying to unify
things we shouldn't unify,
but we're getting as
close as we really should.
So you create a Cast button
using the factory method.
You can actually
specify what color you
want and then off to the races.
You get again all of the
Cast lifecycle for free.
So if the user presses
the Cast button.
The next image is, well,
if they're not casting,
what do you show?
You show different routes.
You show options for where
you can then connect to.
You show the living room.
You show another
cast endpoint that's
already playing something.
If that user had
pressed the Cast button
and they were already
playing media,
we show in an iOS compliant
way in UX compliant
to iOS standards that there's
media already playing,
giving the user a view towards
volume control and play
and pause.
And then if there's
no media playing,
we do the right thing as well.
We handle volume control.
We're now going to
actually cast media.
And what's cool about this is
this gets a lot simpler too.
Again, we manage the session.
We give you access to
that session at any time.
And I'm going to go
forward in just Android.
We can take questions
later on iOS as well.
The first thing you
need to do in your app
is have a concept of being
either local or remote.
So similar to me walking
or traveling and wanting
to watch the Red
Sox on the road,
that would be a concept of
playing the app locally.
If I want to cast, you have
to have a concept of, OK, I'm
playing media remotely.
And you can handle this
enumeration or this logic
in any way that matters
really to your app.
The next thing is you actually
want to cast that media.
You're in a state of
starting a remote session.
So this logic is somewhat
specific to the demo app
and somewhat specific
to our Code Lab,
but the concept is pretty
straightforward is I
want to load some remote media.
I essentially just call and
get a remote media client,
and then essentially
ask for that media
to be built, and
then connect to it.
Now, you do that with a standard
way of generating media,
including in the next
few rows metadata,
like what type of media is this.
And we support a
few different types,
which would help
standardize which controls
are the most appropriate if
the user were actually trying
to control this
with the lock screen
notification or the Cast app.
So a movie is appropriate to
have a play and pause button.
Some other types of media are
inappropriate to have that, so
if it's live media for example.
And then you
effectively give a URL.
And for those of
you who are working
with DRM-enabled
content, nothing really
changes in terms of the
authentication aspects
or trying to manage
different DRM schemes.
You'd still likely use
a custom data channel
to pass over off and manage
authentication and DRM
on the receiver side.
Because honestly in the
authentication side,
every app does things
kind of differently
in minor ways that end
up having major impact.
But the media side of
this is much, much more
straightforward.
And the impact of
that comes in control.
In Android, we now give you
essentially this session
concept where you
can be a listener
to every different
aspect of the session.
And I've put a few
examples up on the screen.
So you can understand
and be a listener
and then change behavior
when starting a Cast session,
using this listener concept.
You can also manage items
like a disconnect event
and handle them
beautifully or gracefully.
And there are a variety
of different mechanisms
or different items that you can
listen to through each session.
What's great about
this is that you don't
have to do heavy lifting
of parts of the session
that you don't want to listen
to or aspects where you kind of
have to say I need
to know everything
in order to do one small thing.
And that is a really
more, I would say,
much more abstractable
architecture
than you've had in the past.
Now, again, all of the code
that you're seeing here
comes from the
Code Lab that will
launch within the next
month with the SDK.
What you get once you've
established a connection,
once you've casted media,
once you've established
or listened to a session
is the full UX of Cast.
So out of the gate, again, this
reduces your development time
a ton.
The first item you get is what's
called a mini-controller, which
is a persistent small controller
that is available to you
to optionally use at
the bottom of the screen
throughout the lifecycle
of your app while casting.
The next area is an
expanded controller.
Now, what's great about
this, and each one
of these controllers, is
you can control the buttons
that matter to you.
You can even control
the count of buttons.
So if you don't need five
buttons in an expanded
controller, we have a way of
using only one, two, three,
and reflowing them beautifully.
So say, for instance,
you're a live app,
and you have no concept
of queue skipping,
which you see here
or play, pause,
you can have the buttons
that matter most for you,
whether that's a star,
kind of thing, favorite,
I like this show, I might
want to watch it again.
Or if you're a music app and
you have a very specific way
or logic around what you do
when someone likes a song,
or like a heart, a
star, a thumbs up,
you can implement that.
Similarly, on the
mini-controller,
if that thumbs up is the
most important thing that
is in the app or thumbs down
does something different
than just an advance queue,
you can put that there as well.
So those two screens are really,
really extensible and flexible.
They come out more mid-summer,
not in the initial release
of the SDK.
But they're available, again,
both on Android and iOS.
On Android, you get
an additional benefit
of having a lock screen
notification automatically.
And what's great about
this is that connects
to the media metadata that
I talked about earlier.
So if you've described what
type of media you're playing,
we do the right thing
on the lock screen.
The last area is something which
we use to help notify users
about Cast.
And what we've found in
studies with top tier apps
is that this actually drives
more usage not just of Cast,
but longer session lengths
as well as more adherence
to the app itself.
It's pretty self-serving for
our team to say, hey, cast more.
But this actually has an
impact for the developer
to help users become more aware
of the Cast feature in the app
as well as Cast sessions
and the Cast usage,
driving longer usage
of the app itself.
The customizable
controllers, I think
this is an area where
you might look at it
and say should I
use them or should I
not use them going forward.
In a new development, I
would say, test them out.
Kick the tires, and
give us feedback
about where you think you
would need more customization
or where you'd need
more capability.
If you're looking at
how you support your app
and you already have a way of
doing second screen control,
like you're a music
app and you've already
had to invest in this for
Bluetooth-type playing,
we can connect to
your logic as well.
And you don't need to use
these template controllers.
But if you want to reduce the
maintenance cost of maintaining
this Cast experience as well
as get the best of our UX
knowledge in terms of what we
test and work with the users
on, in terms of how to do
control of a second screen
experience, this is a
really strong opportunity
to reduce that
burden on your team
while also improving the
user experience in general.
The impact here
is really that we
should reduce development time.
From the beginning,
from maintenance,
from pretty much every
aspect of the SDK.
And reducing development
time initially
is pretty much what
we had done before.
We had given you a set of--
I would say-- SDK components
and then template boilerplate
code to throw into your app.
And honestly, over
time, that initial out
of the box fast start
became pretty costly
because we didn't have
the right abstractions.
We didn't have all
of the components
that you would have needed
to build an end to end app.
What's great about our
framework going forward
is that we reduce
development time for you
in initial development, as well
as reducing the development
time for you in ongoing
maintenance on our SDK
or ongoing maintenance
on your app.
You don't have to be aware
of all the externalities
that you may introduce into
the Cast lifecycle in an app
refactoring.
At the same time, when we
make refactoring or changes,
you don't have to worry about
the impact on your app either.
What's awesome about
this is it includes
all of the elements
of the Cast lifecycle.
And the Cast lifecycle
itself has, again,
some unique aspects.
So as we look at innovating on
that, if we see opportunities
to refine it, we can do so
without impacting your apps
as well.
So for example, if we
find out that a router
in a particular country needs
a few different milliseconds
of latency because
of how it connects,
we don't have to ask you to
refactor your entire app for us
to improve the quality
of the Cast experience.
This gives us a
strong foundation
for improving the Cast model
as well, whether it's making it
faster for users,
whether it's helping you
with doing things like launching
your receiver faster as well.
We can have a much better
framework going forward
without having to interact
with your app lifecycle
The timing of this-- And I'll
talk through this quite a bit--
the timing of this is
we'll launch the new SDK
over the next four weeks.
The core of it is in the
next release of Google Play
services, and on
the iOS side we'll
be releasing it in a
similar time frame.
Going forward we'll
look to release
pretty much on the same
cadence both on Android and iOS
with new features.
We're also not deprecating
CCL and we're not
deprecating their existing
SDK for the time being.
We know a lot of apps take
significant amount of time
to evaluate both when
they change SDK versions,
as well as when they
change SDK capabilities.
We do think that there
is an opportunity
for any new development.
This is really ready to go.
It's ready to go.
And it's much, much
faster to work with,
and it will improve the
maintenance of your app.
Also going forward, the
expanded controllers come out
in the mid-summer
time frame, and we're
looking for feedback
as well if you,
again, see anything
in customization
that you would need.
In general, this has been
developed significantly
with your feedback, whether
feedback around the CCL,
feedback around
the iOS experience.
And we look forward to
incorporating that feedback
into the SDK, because
we, again, have
a much better framework for
being able to roll out updates.
On the side of the
receiver, we're
looking to deliver
a receiver that
brings in a lot of the same
out of the box functionality
towards the end of the summer.
So for the side of it that
resides on the Cast endpoint.
So we're looking and we'll
engage with a lot of you
on the receiver framework
and get feedback as well.
And on the web sender
side, that similarly
should land end of
summer or early fall.
What's next for where
you should go from here?
We're going to be launching
Code Labs with essentially
the exact same
code that you saw,
in that same next four
weeks time period.
You also can dive into full
sample apps, the Cast video
apps, over the next
few weeks as well.
And you'll be able to
see how we did Cast
and how we made
use of the new SDK.
The other side of this is,
again, we love your feedback.
Whether it's engaging with
our developer community
or engaging directly
with our teams,
we'll be right
out in the sandbox
for a good chunk
of the day today,
and many of you in
the room, I know,
we have lots of dialogue
on this SDK as well.
So going forward, our SDK
is much more maintainable,
much more updatable, and has
much less impact on your app.
What's really great about this
is that maintenance should
be reduced and the out
of the box benefit,
again, is about a 40%
reduction in development time.
And this is huge for your
app and for the SDK itself.
I think that's it.
Thank you all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]